[Music]
ha you just saw the sju intro that's a
lie this is honest trailer commentaries
we're back party people sound the
dancehall air horns buh buh buh boo
yeah welcome back to the show where we
talk about the other show that ones on
screen junkies you're here on phantom
entertainment locked in we're going to
talk today about the neverending story
our thoughts our deepest feelings our
most intimate of intimates then
afterwards we're gonna talk we're gonna
respond back to some viewer mail because
you guys send in your questions in the
mail and and we're gonna see some
deleted scenes and stuff like that right
that's how the show works yeah we
haven't done in a minute but that's
about it
yeah I honestly don't know why we
stopped except somebody it must've been
Roth asked like Oh
Korona the the world's falling apart do
you still want to do commentaries and my
instinct was just to say no because it
sounds like less work but unfortunately
wait we can still do this show we're
gonna be here for two more years you
guys get used to it
it became the balance right at first it
was like yay less work but now like that
there's literally no movie news on a
day-to-day basis coming up with
something to do has become much more
work and so we needed the level back out
this is true I will take one small
bummer break of a moment to say r.i.p
carl reiner comedic legend what am i
heroes two thousand year old man played
that with my parents probably as
responsible for getting me into comedy
as god de Bary or something like you
know the stuff you like when you're
seven years old
yeah but he's aged so well the simpsons
carl reiner dave barry the things
spencer liked when he was seven years
old yeah name for a rock band Spencer
Gilbert there you go
so just positive to show him your
respect and love today but today we're
talking about something uh also a bleak
and depressing the neverending story
what are your your twos personal
histories with this film
uh this was my favorite movie when I was
a kid this was by this I know
such a bummer summer man um this was the
movie that I loved like when everyone I
know you guys like your dark crystals
and you loved I you know when dancing
and magic gaming and dancing and weird
weird dongs in that movie but this was
my movie like I loved neverending story
I you know I love the Billy Crystal bits
I loved the weird rock dude I I our text
has my entire whole heart I loved say my
name like I just have so which I guess
is also the thing for that Beyonce song
but yeah I I just I really really love
this movie it's like it is deeply
ingrained inside the dnl DNA a video
record there you go Joe I do remember
being a child and also consistently
conflating have fun storming the castle
from princess bride with this this with
this creature my second I love this
movie when I was a kid you turn it on
and stare at it and that was kind of all
there was to it
my second Renaissance with this movie
was of course when New Found Glory
dropped their EP of pop punk cover movie
themes which included the neverending
story in 1999
[Applause]
yeah I don't think ever the song he
never got had room for me you were never
director records grim oh yeah yeah yeah
you're right yeah yeah yeah okay Jimmy
world I like Jimmy Eat World I remember
okay okay come on major you've been to a
Warped Tour I see you I've not been move
or pep into a weenie roast been to many
a weenie roast okay that counts that
gets it what story is hot that's all I
have to say it's always very hot and
comfortable there's never a good way to
work it's always very I especially if
you get older anyway sorry like see how
they run fair kissing I would like the
LA Ren fair you gotta go really yeah
what really warp often so speak give Ren
fares I remember liking this movie it
wasn't like part of my my identity or
like my rotation it was it was I
remember at an age-appropriate time
having a crush on the Empress at an
age-appropriate time as a child yeah and
I remember also thinking a tray was like
super cool man then I want to be him her
name is child like actually a child
actually agent that's the thing isn't
one of those like nine hundred like her
eternal beings and in the body of a
child errs now when I first saw her I
was a child of about her age and I was
like she's pretty I should hold hands
and bring each other's hair because
that's what being a lesbian gay looks
like when you're that age I wanna braid
her hair her braids are so pretty so
yeah that's that that is what I thought
very innocently and then now as I grow
up I'm like yeah I think a straight guy
at that age also it extended as far as I
want to hold her hand right yeah yeah
pretty much yeah I like to tear you a
lot to look white dudes in the south
have a complicated relationship with
really love and Native American stuff
because we are all literally told at
Birth that we all share some weird
Native American blood and we were told
that until the day we die
that's why I give Elizabeth Warren a
little less guff because the day she was
born someone was like here at
Massachusetts
doesn't matter like no Spenny I think
we're me or not or not people of a
certain age but we're a little older
than you and there was a time when
literally everyone was like my
granddad's Native American not when you
were older but like when you were a
child that was part of like your family
lore was like when you went into
kindergarten you were like like
granddad's part of the Cherokee tribe
and everyone's like do you know if any
other driver like that's like a part of
a very crappy Americana so that that
said Atreyu and Bastian's love for him
definitely went on a bookshelf along
with my copy of my well-worn copy of
Indian in the cupboard produced by
Kathleen Kennedy fun fact right there so
yeah I guess what what really stuck out
to me though on the rewatch was how grim
and dark and depressing this film was
just non-stop just like even in its look
it's like all this you know chiaroscuro
like dark lighting and it's muddy and
it's depressing and all the animals want
to die I don't I don't remember that
from the first time around that this the
the universe is destroyed in this movie
that's the whole thing you go up to the
nightmare and dude it's like I'm a dog
but not like the cool kind of dogs that
you like I'm like a dog's butt destroys
humanity and that's the whole thing with
art I don't know what I was younger I
definitely understood that our attacks
was a electing to self not live anymore
because it's not self mentally not
conventionally not live anymore because
of what was happening with him yeah yeah
I got it I still loved it how's a dark
weird kid man and horse chose to drown
and even here I even come orc at the end
is is sitting in a hole cuz he failed
and is like well if all I got left is to
try to kill this kid then I'll just go
ahead and try to do it everything's
screwed anyway yeah everywhere
everywhere everyone said really said and
then I was having a tough time
recalling the story of this film and it
turns out that that is the stories just
like yeah the world's falling apart and
it does because people don't believe in
the imagination yeah that's right it's
never-ending except for one sweet sweet
boy all right it's actually it's been a
while since I actually thought about
this movie even though it came out today
so this was last week's movie so let's
let's play the trailer and see if I can
refresh our memories on the neverending
story halting this summer we're getting
honest about summer blockbusters past
and present this is honest trailers
blockbusters summer what it's worth I
cannot hear what's happening just some
party and all the dead authors estates
that won't Disney ripped off now embark
on an epic tale of magic are nomads in
the brain of tradition in that it's wait
depressing and thoroughly German the
neverending story to a world of
neverending miseries where the heroes
are bullied the locations need therapy
and existence is collapsing in on itself
like a fortnight storm made of nihilism
to the point where horses literally
drown themselves in sadness that horse
didn't actually drown but it's the kind
of movie that really makes you think
they wanted to this is very bleak and I
guess it is the German parts of me that
feel it so hardly but ya know like
they've that uh that I'd have nightmares
about that like scene of our attacks and
I've seen it obviously but I think it is
some one of those things where like
where it comes up we have to talk about
it I have had nightmares about that just
the idea of you know there's like a
horse it's like I everything sucks so I
want to just like see dudes and in this
case could do things
yeah
so I looked into this scene a little bit
like the making of because well first of
all the rumor was the horse died right
so you want to find out did the horse
die and you know the bellow notice that
horse the people in the production say
no not only did the horse die but the
actor who played a tre you got to keep
the horse which to me sounds like oh we
went to live on a farm somewhere seems
like that's what my parents told me when
our first cat died they were like Oh tre
you kept the cat cats in a movie now
what is sad but the cat is not whether
the horse the horses ultimate fate is is
up in the air but they had to actually
stop production and because it was very
difficult and they had to do extra
training to train a horse to stand still
while it was on a platform being lowered
horse neck deep into mud we maybe the
horses freaked out that it was weed all
of the stuff maybe that was one of the
stuffs we didn't have to do but you know
it's not it's not Milo and Otis is my
own Otis the one it's not Milo and Otis
yeah my own Otis yeah that's a even
grimmer one if you don't know what we're
talking about that's the reason why
movies now say no actually animals were
harmed in the making of this and to put
that up after Milo notice because
actually I mean they treated Atreyu
about as well as they treated our tax
yeah because that was a small boy doing
his own stunts billy crystal's the only
one that got away from this like
unscathed yeah there was a thing where
the director what Wolfgang Pearson or
someone else maybe was talking about how
easy and professional Bastian was on set
and how difficult Moody and tricking is
s every time you yell action they like
hitting him with like a pillowcase full
of doorknobs in a room yeah we got a
window and the other one was watching a
horse die what are you talking about the
other the other urban legend I don't
know if this one's true or not is that
he buddy got to keep the corpse
he got that glue he took that glue home
and maybe he used the glue too like he
was like the rumor was like he broke his
back or something like he had to have
back surgery after this because they
were alone about that damn tree too much
yeah is every German movie like this
yeah they don't they believe in nothing
Lebowski they are nihilists I think the
only other German movie I've seen is
funny games which is the other grandma
actually never let me watch German
movies she still doesn't if she's heard
I've seen a German movie she'll send me
a text through my bleep German movies
then I think it's time for a film
festival the only other German movie
I've seen is Rob's teen videos du hast
yeah du hast and and the Rammstein
performance at the beginning of xxx yes
was that German no I'd love to keep
playing was that German but let's keep
playing the others thanks to Fantasia's
lacks child labor laws only two small
boys and one little girl will fight
against the nothing
there's bastion armed with a magic book
and the bowl cut of every young male
protagonist from 1973 to 1998 yep do you
have that bowl cut Jo yes
bowl cut yeah I didn't find a % had that
bowl cut and then when I rebelled
against my parents in middle school I
just took the ball cut and parted it
right there oh that was even cooler yeah
yeah the Mike trim yeah that is your
version of when I had that be like early
2000s like 2000 times maybe like bangs
like that's your version yes yeah yeah
um you seen Nirvana video and your
standard what I don't understand is like
what was the herb ball cut what was the
rosetta stone like who were we all
trying to look like cuz every King had
that who was patient zero that's really
yeah
was it dandy in the shining he's the
earliest bull cut in that grid was there
like a really cool kid in the little
house I have to sneeze wait
welcome your sneeze bubble your seeds by
saying that run is German thank you so
in the chat point out that apparently
Ramstein it's supposed to end as like
fine like I know okay good to know mama
cause of Ramstein I'm a column Ramstein
but I won't have a word of yeah that
went out to the Family Values tour it
was dope as hell after ass Cuban corn
did their duet Ramstein came on there
and just do hostage the out of that
stains I love them I got a dude call out
some hour pause okay I want to know can
anyone in the chat tell me what's the
German word for the feeling of
anticipation and expectation
Tindra sadness when you're waiting to
find out whether Run Lola Run is German
or not because I know there's a word and
while you guys are looking that up hey
make sure you watch hey fandom tomorrow
was gonna be today and now it's tomorrow
at noon right after sju we have nolan
north he's the voice of great Nolan
Nolan Nolan Nolan Nolan he's the voice
of Drake from a charted not the voice of
Drake the rapper although I think he
should voice both Joe if you ask me it's
gonna be great hosted by Trisha
Hershberger who is also great you should
definitely check that one out and then
if you want to watch previous hey
fandoms we're just should they're over
on fandom calm specifically phantom calm
slash video and we've got links in the
descriptions to check those out and to
also check out how you can get involved
in Direct Relief to assist in coverage
nineteen fighting and then also how to
get involved in black lives matter and
then Thursday at noon we're doing a new
thing called the fandom five it was a
trivia thing we were doing on Instagram
for a little bit and now it yeah
graduated there's links in the
description if you're a Pokemon head a
polka polka master Jeff a quote if you
are our Polka master
come play if you answer five questions
correctly you're gonna win some money
and then you're gonna get an option to
come back answer five even harder
questions and win more money show up and
let me try to give you money and those
are the call else win j-stars that's
absolutely what we should have called it
up
well good money not that I didn't love
our contractually obligated and
heartfelt call outs Joe but I now
totally forgot what we were talking
about so you're gonna have to pick it up
from there we were kind of the works no
we were talking about but yeah what's
the German word for that run with Lola
run all right you tell me in the chat
let's keep going with the trailer all
right eight kilo of it is schools creepy
hookup attic to pull a fanfic oh we
glossed over that attic there's bones in
there there's so many bones so a weird
story from college just for creepy bone
store so I went to and I'm more they
give you sue I went to Cornish College
of the Arts and one of at that time we
didn't have a proper campus and so one
of the things that we would do was we
would have our classes at a Masonic Hall
and it had all of them know and we would
like go roam through everything to get
like costumes all the stuff I have so
many weird I didn't know this was an
amazing I call stories but one of them
is just bones man just like you go and
not even like you have to hunt for the
bones they had Mason bones just out we
we assumed they were plastic we were not
told but man just like a UH just like
bones bones where they don't know
Masonic bones Wow I assumed they were
fake plastic please don't murder me my
Sonic's um it's wholly gonna get
murdered
um but ya know just bones you revealed
the secret of the bones you were so
close to knowing where the Grail is yeah
you chose wisely yeah I knew they'd like
to play dress up so the costume thing
makes sense
oh there there's a whole lighting thing
I can tell you guys off air okay this is
a ten minute story but yeah mostly it
was if you go into a weird hallway
that's dark just like that one the Danny
that odd that he wouldn't Danny but he
went into and not just bones and then
people use the bones for their scene
studies and it was weird
what was your school's designated
hook-up place mine was the senior garden
high school or college
I guess high school college it was just
kind of everywhere high literally
anyone's house because our parents were
not home there you go Arzo yeah we just
had like this tunnel that can our high
school was two buildings and there was
this weird tunnel that was only lit by
like two small skylights to connect them
and in the middle of it there was a big
giant kind of phallic statue that looked
like a combination of a Wang and a
lipstick I don't understand what the
point of it was but that's where that
poem sexual energy yeah two things
happened there people put their gum
there and people hooked up there awesome
like a stasis a crank up that Rammstein
we're gonna do some motion anyways
that's where that's definitely where
Bastion holds up is the bone her so many
pounder I made a key to it was like
right next to it so it's like kids
definitely sneak in there and hook up he
like dragged a mattress over to read on
you know what's going on there yeah and
if you'd like watch the movie and even
if even just in bookshelves and stuff
and just a little cubby holes there's
just bones there are what there's a lot
of bones in that room huh so many bones
oh and like a wolf's head or something
no wolves Hannah because sure yeah all
right let's keep going up attic so pull
a fanfic 101 and do a self insert is the
savior of the universe what a party they
know him back check saddle up with
oh man too soon and right along with the
tray you a young warrior from the Tiger
Beat tribe he'll get himself absolutely
wrecked from start to finish
[Applause]
so grumpy upset what a diva stop putting
mud on me just ranting keep gonna be
potter jr. in the movie troll experience
a story about the power of storytelling
itself that's really weak in the
storytelling department what it's a
bunch of random obstacles then it ends
out of nowhere it's got all the dynamics
of a Super Mario level but what it lacks
that's one to talk about that because
it's like this isn't the story is such
like a it's a shaggy dog story right
with with the luckdragon
it's like he's sent to like go ask
somebody who maybe knows about a thing
but they can't help you with the thing
so they say go ask somebody else and
then maybe they'll have the thing that
will fight the nothing and then maybe oh
actually all you needed was with you all
along it's not much of a story right no
you're correct
stand up for your fetcher
no I was a child children are stupid
our brains are much someone say my name
at the end and I was like that is plot
advancement yeah I know there's a whole
lot more to the book as we get into
towards the end of the trailer I've
never read the book yeah but I I feel
like there's a whole lot more to the
whole Bastian thing and yeah this movie
just doesn't do it they definitely
Golden Compass this thing with the first
Golden Compass movie where they're like
let's go to the third act credits but we
were so poor ripped like they were they
were good there was obviously great
fantasy happening right then but it
wasn't like now when you can just like
look at fantasy because you were going
on HBO or whatever we didn't have you
know 12 in it at like hours of fantasy
every week so we took what we could get
yes and we would great guy yeah yeah if
that dragon is gonna be ended by a
creepy bone sex room bed then that's the
dragon you're gonna take man that is
what you got all right well let's keep
going a bowl but what it lacks in depth
it makes up for is been away curry
because their world is powered by the
imagination of Bastian's world and
bastions world is powered by the
imagination of our world which in turn
sparks the audience's imagination
because we're watching both of their
worlds joining us all together in a
never ending story jerk so grab a
sandwich one thing we didn't get into in
the trailer is that creepy-ass bookstore
owner oh you know that's usually a real
red flag if like books burner has like
special books that he can't show you
unless you're really special maybe come
back after hours he'll show you his
special books that if our older children
I mean it was it turned out I don't know
good and bad it was bad but for a
different reason
yeah he almost died he's just real mean
and crappy and very sarcastic yeah and
the bet but then yeah when the crazy old
man gets to the point where he's like
have you ever felt the sweat robinson
crusoe that that's when you leave that's
when you get out of that bookstore so
quickly well it was either better get
thrown in the dumpster again yeah yeah
if you're a kid and someone wants to
show you the unsafe books that's that's
your cue to leave we can excuse that
that's true this movie Purple Rain
people got thrown in dumpsters good yeah
so is our worlds some other worlds
imagination is that the implication here
dreaming us up right now yeah I think so
well because okay so is that the
neverending story is that every layer of
reality is the imagination oh I did
address it just like ranted about this
for way too long and since you were much
funnier than me wisely cut it way down
but yeah just ended with like him
getting a nosebleed yes because it's
because because that it's like so then
if Bastian take
Falkor out of Fantasia and brings Falkor
to his world is that really his roller
is that a new splinter Fantasia where he
is just inserted elements into that
world and are we watching that world and
so we're not a part yeah it's it's a
whole thing
yeah reality keeps splintering ya know
when the Hulk gets the crystal does that
mean that now the childlike Empress is
the adult like Empress had changed the
past why'd you say like that we Seinfeld
with that one you can't change the past
Ruffalo does that scene effort if I
recall in endgame you can't change the
past no wise disobey the future and then
one other thing I just kind of realized
is in the book Bastian is kind of kind
of a plump really nerdy kid I think
they've really lay on them for not
smelling great and like they really but
I realized it's like ready player one
it's another ready player one reference
from ready player one where I think they
just made their kid and cuz in the book
ready player one he's kind of the same
right I think he's like just like a real
stereotypical indoor kid and yeah I give
him every stereotype of a picked on
child you but they don't cast indoor
kids to be in movies so just made me
wonder if that in itself was a rare he's
got a ponytail and to never yeah had
paint on his jeans
yeah Ginetta meta meta I just feel bad
for whoever has to watch us watch hentai
you know yeah someone right now is
imagining you watching him touch
watching Waluigi hentai sorry
it's a livin some German word for that
while toad still demands you say his
name keep crashing of our world which in
turn sparks the audience's imagination
because we're watching both of their
worlds joining us all together in a
never ending story jerk so grab a
sandwich eat an entire Apple core curl
up in a blanket for one of the weirdest
hits of the 80s that you mostly remember
for the amazing luckdragon
as in it's amazing luck that the FBI
never seized his computer I like
children you were unconscious and you
talked in your sleep yeah rocking out to
the dope Giorgio Moroder score
but you may not remember that this story
didn't truly end no it had a sequel with
jonathan brandis a 3/4 starring Jack
Black and both of them ignored the
second half of the book it's based on
where passion becomes a power-hungry
madman that tries to take over the
kingdom
wow that's dark even for this story
let's just end with some happy Falkor
shots I think this is looking ahead sort
of this is a question from a from a
viewer but we'll do it now do you have
any experience for the sequel because I
don't thoughts do yeah this is from Adam
Halder
by the way I would say have you ever
seen any of the Wizard of Oz sequels
because those are somehow both better
written and less terrifying okay that
tells you anything yeah yeah but your
night I'm saying like them it's
especially like the yeah they're not
they're not great although I will say
I've not seen them in a while they were
one of those things where my mom was
like hey I was in Walmart and they had a
three pack my understanding is that the
author is like those are terrible and I
want to acknowledge them know it's that
house though mm-hmm yes you do dang
right let's let's finish up this trailer
reading lamo DP being ball deep that's
great uh Dewey the wolf who cried
possibly I'm just gonna Pat myself on
the back fur that's a my first but not
my last Discworld reference I've been
reading all the Discworld novels they're
great
Joe you know Joe view your that would be
a joke that wouldn't what are you doing
sorry
I've never gotten into this world it's
like fantasy comedy it's like
Hitchhiker's Guide with the Wizards well
everything about that screams Joe to me
come on Joe Joe
and they were common collaborators and I
could talk about that series all day
like I will Danielle will talk about
that afternoon that's the reference is
you naming the turtle in neverending
story
is something from a different story
create a new neverending story okay yeah
yeah sure that's that's a reality now
it's a whole thing is that the universe
of a giant turtle it's yeah stack of
elephants okay anyways keep going
that's whoa who cried boy I'm coke made
of rocks as you can see the first time
you read the red wedding say my name say
my name have fun storming this arm turbo
the racing snail that one Goblin from
labyrinth booby-trap the biggest block
of butter we've ever seen dubbed white
knight hop this could be serious
actually filmed his lines in German
Gumby Mickey Mouse et c-3po wait what is
this ready player one and how your mom
watches TV
[Music]
trying to watch mom shut up My Beautiful
Dark Twisted Fantasy I think I know what
killed bastions mom Salmonella hmm
yeah raw eggs and orange juice frappe
yeah I wouldn't recommend anything raw
egg related certainly not in America our
eggs are Salmonella plus um let's do
some deleted scenes I believe that's
what we do now if I've recalled yes so
here's what we cut to the point where
horses literally drown themselves in
sadness who drowns a horse in a kids
movie
oh right German story books Marge look
only so good there's another thing we
there's one thing we cut that I guess
they make it in there where it's like a
través starts with a British accent and
you got the British accent beat out of
them yes anyways that's a joke bit we
that we cut as well cuz at the beginning
of the film he's like my I am Atreyu
from the tribe of the people they don't
need me hey yeah everybody's like screw
this I have too many bruised ribs he's a
diva diva alright anyways sorry here's
the rest of the billion see Milhouse the
pagemaster Johnny Depp child soldiers
boy soldier a one-man Wolf Pack insanity
war an American Werewolf in Fantasia
drogon lucky rouler our like a dungeon
dragon dro dog bold Yeller to scratch a
predator the voice of Skeletor No
the story that ends abruptly this is the
book that never ends yes it goes on and
on my friends some people started
reading it not knowing what it was and
they'll continue reading it forever just
because this is the nice have done John
alright that's that let's see if I could
find some comments and questions from
viewers like you
Luis Valenzuela if this video hits 500
likes by the end can we have everyone
sing the song well I always say I can't
watch myself while I do this I think
that would start 17 new dimensions are
we at 500 likes not quite at the end so
it smash that like button if you want us
to sing but you know what
alright is that the Zachary tell us is
that the Rocketeer behind you pretty
cool that's great that is pretty cool
Joe what's that skull you got back there
well I did a tabletop RPG actual play
show said in the Star Wars universe and
this skull is part of my characters
costume and a fan cosplay tis my
character and made the set of resin and
send it to me as a gift
it's awesome wow that's really do sweet
I just have this fan behind me for
fandom alright somebody saying me like
the sequel better okay good for you
panthro writes I saw this movie every
year between 1986 and 1994 in a huge
tent on a field just outside the town I
grew up in with all the children between
4 and 12 years that live there that's
that's yeah just say where what the
rules of that were very parents doing
while you were all the tent every
Harvest Moon story fed and there's some
definite midsummer things happening in
the tent next door
all right Scarlett mi Scarlett me right
the very first paragraph on atom riches
Wikipedia is that he's the haircut that
inspired the pageboy bowl-cut atom rich
whose atom rich see Bastian really
I was asking oh yeah yeah yeah that was
a haircut good enough to last a few
decades or just the bowl cut but we're
all gonna be there by the end of
quarantine I can bring it back yeah
that's all that's all for your questions
right another pop in anymore if you see
any more you're mostly just trying to
get you guys to sing now but we still
haven't quite yet 500 but I'm already
tired right well we'll just sing the
never ending we won't say story yeah
leaving more than ever guys thanks for
watching we gotta get a clue right oh oh
we do that too I mean oh shoot
next look if you're into things that
slither and and you know squiggle around
on the ground you might not like next
week's on this trailer and we will see
you then thank you so much for watching
what a fun return we'll be here next
week maybe we'll even find the get lawn
out of his cave who knows
we'll be there next week the next
episode of Oz trailer commentaries see
you tomorrow
[Music]
you